we will discuss the succession after I
wear the crown
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a prediction video today I want to talk
about a very popular and controversial
scene that happened in the season 7
finale I want to talk about the scene
between Tyrion and Cersei Lannister the
reason why this scene became so
interesting is because Terry and went to
negotiate with Cersei but it ended as
soon as Tyrion realized Cersei was
pregnant and we never got to see what
Tyrion said to Cersei to change her mind
about helping against the army of the
dead I know everyone already discussed
what they thought happened during the
scene because I've seen a lot of
different videos about it but I want to
propose another option I just want to go
over a few of those scenes again and see
if they can all be tied together in a
way that not too many people have
mentioned I think the most popular
theory is that Tyrion betrayed Daenerys
by promising something to Cersei in
order to get Cersei to send her troops
north to help during the Great War
that's actually not a bad theory at all
but I think it's only partially right so
let me show you a handful of scenes from
season 7 then I will pick them apart and
tell you how I came to this specific
conclusion first let me start with what
led to all of this in this season 7
finale there was a huge meeting in the
dragon pit John Daenerys Tyrion and
everyone else wanted to show Cersei the
true threat beyond the wall in hopes of
getting Cersei support in the only war
that matters the Great War they were
hoping they could get a temporary truce
with Cersei because they believe they
need everyone United together in order
to defeat the night king Cersei said she
would help them stop the night king
under one condition
once the army of the Dead were defeated
Johnson Oh would have to stay in the
north and not choose sides and help
support Daenerys against the Lannisters
but Jon Snow had already bent the knee
to Daenerys and he was not willing to
lie and say that he wouldn't help her
take back the throne for House Targaryen
this was a deal breaker for Cersei so
she said she was not helping and that's
when she stormed off to the castle this
is what led to Tyrion deciding to go
talk to his sister in private hoping he
could convince her to help them anyway
when Tyrion went and talked to Cersei
she made it pretty clear he could not
change her mind but something had
and something was said to Circe that
persuaded her into going back to the
dragon pit where she then said she would
send all of her banners north to help
John and Daenerys but what could Tyrion
have said what could he have promised
Circe stubborn ass to go back out there
and say this many people immediately
believe Tyrion had to have betrayed
Daenerys in that moment how else could
Tyrion have convinced Cersei to help
unless he gave her an offer she couldn't
refuse well we all know whatever Tyrion
promised her must not have been good
enough because Cersei ended up lying
anyway
Cersei later tells Jaime she isn't
helping them she's not sending any men
north but Tyrion might not have known
this Tyrion may still believe they have
a deal and the reason why I think Tyrion
still believes they have a deal is
because of a certain look Tyrion had on
his face later in the episode but I'm
gonna touch on that later
I think Tyrion did offer Cersei
something and that's because of what
Cersei said when she got back to the
dragon pit when Cersei said she would
send all of her banners north
she also said this the darkness is
coming for us all
face it together and when the Great War
is over perhaps you'll remember I chose
to help but no promises or assurances
from any of you Circe said we will face
it together and when the Great War is
over perhaps you will remember that I
chose to help with no promises or
assurances from any of you she was
talking to John and Danny when she said
that she didn't get any promises or
assurances from John or Danny but she
did get one from Tyrion in private
that's why she didn't look at Tyrion
when she said that but the question
still remains
what did Tyrion promise or assure Cersei
now we need to look at the conversation
Tyrion and Cersei had in private during
this conversation there was one thing
Tyrion kept saying over and over again
he swore to Cersei that he loved her
children no matter what Cersei thinks of
him she can't deny that Tyrion had love
for her kids which we all know was true
in fact there was a lot of talk of
children during the entire season seven
Circe's pregnancy was talked about many
times last season and Daenerys kept
talking about not being able to have
children of her own
even Jorah Mormont talked about John
having children this was a big theme
throughout the whole season and it had a
major presence in the finale as well in
the talk of children as where Tyrion and
Cersei private conversation was cut off
maybe you're hungry joy I had the right
idea get on a boat take those who matter
you're pregnant
I think that made it pretty clear that
whatever Tyrion said next must have had
something to do with Circe's unborn
child
Tyrion knows Cersei loved her children
he knows that Cersei would do just about
anything to protect her children
Cersei even reminded us of this during
that conversation she said when that
white came charging at her there was
only one thing she was thinking about
and that was keeping her family safe the
ones who matter most and she was rubbing
her belly as she was saying that that's
what tipped Tyrion off that she was
pregnant in the first place when Tyrion
figured out Cersei was pregnant this is
when he thought he had Cersei right
where he wanted her
Tyrion thought he could pull on those
heartstrings by promising safety to
Circe's child and that would get Cersei
to play ball because he assumed she
would do anything for her kids
I think Tyrion promised Cersei something
big but whatever he did promise her was
a lie
think about what Tyrion said to John
after Cersei left the parler scene I'm
pleased you bent the knee to our queen I
would have advised it how'd you asked
but have you ever considered learning
how to lie every now and then just a bit
I'm not gonna swear an oath I can't
uphold Tyrion told John II should have
lied he should have lied long enough for
Cersei to help them Daenerys even agreed
and I think Tyrion went in there what
that same attitude Jon Snow had too much
pride to lie to Cersei but Tyrion
doesn't tyrion was going to go in there
and say whatever he needed to say in
order to get Cersei to help them
Tyrion would promise her the stars in
the moon if he had to and I think that's
what he did but I also think he fears
that his lie may be coming back to bite
him in the ass and I'll tell you why
Tyrion may have promised sir see a
future alliance or even a marriage
between Circe's kid and Danny's kid now
I know that sounds crazy but just hear
me out
Tyrion promised this thinking he would
never have to follow through with it in
Tyrians eyes it was an empty promise
because Tyrion assumes Daenerys can't
have any kids
because Daenerys told him this how do we
ensure your vision indoors after you
break the wheel how do we make sure it
stays broken you want to know who sits
on the Iron Throne after I'm dead is
that it you say you can't have children
but there are other ways of choosing a
successor but we know this has been
ontarians mind in the episode right
before this Tyrion was asking Dany about
the future he wanted to know what she
intended on doing to keep the wheel
broken once she was dead this pissed
Danny off because she didn't want Tyrion
thinking about replacing her already
not before she even said on the Iron
Throne but Tyrion can't help but plan
for the future
Daenerys said she can't have kids but
she did say they would talk about a
successor once she said on the throne
so when Tyrion found out Cersei was
pregnant what could he promise her to
get her to help but it wouldn't be a
promise he would have to worry about
keeping later
Tyrion knows Cersei and Daenerys will
never call the truce together but Tyrion
could promise a truce between their
children or even an alliance or marriage
but in the vaca Tyrians mind he's not
worried about this because he knows
Danny can't have kids but that might not
be true either think about this for a
second when Tyrion and Cersei if she was
pregnant that's when the scene ends in
an immediately cuts to Jon and Daenerys
talking about the future of House
Targaryen this is when John tells Danny
that maybe she can have kids maybe marry
master was full of [ __ ] and I think this
is interesting because this is a hint as
to what Tyrion is telling Cersei as the
scene cuts away
Tyrion told John II should have lied so
that's what he's doing he's promising
something he knows he can't give but it
backfires at the end of the episode
that's why Tyrion had that look on his
face when Jon and Daenerys went into the
cabin together it was like a punch to
the stomach because Tyrion realized he
might be held responsible for his
promise to Cersei if Daenerys does in
fact get pregnant and produce an heir
now we all know Cersei lied but Tyrion
doesn't know that yet he still thinks
Cersei will want him to hold up to his
promises and assurances
that's why Tyrion made that face as Jon
and Daenerys was hooking up he doesn't
want this to become a reality because he
knows Cersei will want
what was promised to her or I could be
totally wrong but I feel like whatever
Tyrion promised may have something to do
with Daenerys having an error and that's
why he looked so troubled when John and
Danny was having sex then you combine it
with all the other scenes I showed you
in this video and I kind of think it
fits that doesn't mean it will happen or
that's what did happen but I thought it
was worth mentioning it's something to
consider but let me know your thoughts
on all of this what do you believe
Tyrion promised Cersei whatever he did
promise her doesn't really matter
because Cersei isn't helping but dead
Tyrion betrayed Daenerys anyway or did
he lie to let me know what you think
before I go I want to read a few things
some of my patreon supporters had to say
about this scene when I knew I wanted to
make this video I left a post on my
patreon letting everyone know what the
video I was making next and I told them
to leave me some thoughts about what
happened during the Cersei and Tyrion
scene and this is what some of them had
to say Ottawa stuff said the Mad Queen
has two priorities announcing her
pregnancy for mercy and figuring out
Tyrion strategy she's also psyching
herself up for Jaime's confrontation
kaseylee said I honestly feel some form
of deal had to have been made
I think tyrion told her to lie to say
forces were on their way but he probably
wanted her to increase King's landings
defenses in case the fight in the north
fails there's no way Cersei would have
walked out of that meeting originally
when Jon said Danny was his queen and
then come back out and fakely offered
all her armies no questions asked just
for the sake of seeming worthy of the
throne that's not how she works
rani hackett says Cersei always has a
hidden agenda and Tywin told her she's
not as smart as she thinks Terry and on
the other hand is quite smart
so Tyrion may have used the fact that
she was what Jaime's child over her hand
however I just don't see Tyrion in full
trust of Cersei I can't wait to see
where you're going to take us on this
one dan may've Gibson says that scene
was reminiscent of the scene during the
Battle of Blackwater Bay when Cersei
said on the Iron Throne with Tommen and
she was telling him the story of the
mother lion and her
KUB she spoke of how she would protect
him and one day all the other creatures
would bow down to him when Tywin walked
into the throne room after having saved
the day Tywin was shown to be the
protector and Cersei the cub when Tyrion
kill Tywin in Circe's mind the Lions
lost their protector and everything fell
to ruin Cersei will not make that
mistake again she is determined to be
the protector of her new unborn cub at
any cost and while she's at it get full
revenge on Tyrion who she blames for
everything she is openly and consciously
lying to Tyrion he represents everything
she hates in the world all the
destructive forces past and present that
have rallied against her he represents
everything she hates in herself as well
because he is able to bring out her the
truths that she doesn't want to face
that he is really blameless that her
choices and behavior have been
disastrous I think I'm gonna start doing
that for now on whenever I plan on
making a new prediction or theory videos
I will let my patreon supporters know
what it will be about and to leave me
some thoughts so I can feature them at
the end of each of those videos that's a
little something extra I can do for
those of you who continue to support the
channel so I do appreciate some of that
extra feedback let me know what you
think about what they had to say as well
but I do want to thank everyone for
watching I truly appreciate all of you
taking the time out of your day to watch
the video I hope everyone has a great
day I will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]